what up guys so every single week we
always try to get a weekend yummy
breakfast with me ma bear and tyka and
we found out in this hotel they make
pancakes bigger than tiger's head
there's a pancake bigger than your face
a big old pancake you want to eat it
yeah yeah
so it's called hash house a gogo and
we're gonna go check it out
[Music]
[Music]
i actually don't know anything you
actually told me that we're gonna go get
pancakes bigger than tycho's face and
i'm like oh [ __ ] let's go so we're
inside the link hotel and so far
everything in here is really really nice
really new even the music's like super
posh so it makes me feel like they only
pick really high quality cool stuff to
put in here so i'm like pretty excited i
feel like it's gonna be really good
there's actually a bunch of hash holo
gogos in nevada the one that we're in is
inside the link hotel because it was
highly rated and what they're known for
is twisted farm food so think
traditional american breakfast eggs
bacon hash browns corned beef hash
but huge
and with a gourmet twist let's get lost
in breakfast today baby
[Music]
micah what's your favorite kind of
breakfast
[Music]
the drinks
you'll have the banana latte yes
can i get the campfire sports s'mores
can i get that ice cream that one is not
because they torch it oh
that's the only one
okay i'll get that hot orange juice a
little pink one yeah and then three
waters absolutely and can i get one of
your world famous blueberry pancakes
and can we also get a chicken or waffles
yeah baking cones with that is that okay
for you
yeah any of the national sauce on the
side the spicy sauce yes please and
we're looking for a third thing what do
you recommend um well the chicken
benedict is one of our best sellers or i
will do the trauma hash
yes all of it perfect anything else
no okay okay so right now it is 9 30 and
we just sat down we put our names down
at around like 8 30. so it's like a good
hour wait but there's a pro tip okay any
time that you want to eat breakfast you
have to do it before 10 a.m so that you
can avoid all the crowd but for here
because it's so poppin and it's so
popular you're already looking for like
a minimum 30 minute wait so the sooner
you can get here the better
so i saw you reading the menu and you're
like campfire s'mores latte and i'm like
s'mores i freaking love s'mores graham
cracker melted chocolate marshmallow got
that in a drink that's super delicious
have to try that and every time i go to
a restaurant for the first time i always
have to get their flagship items you
know every restaurant they're known for
like their top one two or three things
so for sure we came here looking for the
biggest pancakes and i think we found it
and i got the blueberry lemon pancake on
the menu there's a big chicken and
waffles thing and even on yelp everyone
keeps raving about the sage fried
chicken and waffles so when i heard that
i'm like ooh sage that must mean it's a
very herby chicken i saw the crust
that's super crunchy and it's a big old
stack with waffles and then you have the
nashville hot sauce it sounds like the
best chicken waffles i'm ever gonna have
i didn't know what to get for the third
one so i always asked the server for
recommendation and she recommended
either the chorizo cash or fried chicken
benedict we already got the fried
chicken in the chicken and waffles so
i'm like oh let's change up the palette
a little bit let's go with the chorizo
hash because i love chorizo and i love
hashes you guys know me i love making
skews and skillets or it's all mis-mash
and the runny egg and the yolk and all
that stuff so i'm super excited with
this big hearty breakfast
[Music]
the banana latte all right here we go
should i mix this i feel like i need to
mix this yeah
[Music]
does it taste like banana no
it doesn't taste like the movie no what
does it taste like milk and coffee
[Music]
no
kinda underwhelming
i don't taste the banana
it's okay maybe if you order this tell
them
go heavy on the banana does anyone else
do this when i have whipped cream on the
top like it was intended to all go
together so what i do is i'll pull my
straw out and start sucking from the top
of the whipped cream and then continue
to suck as i'm pushing it down so i can
get a mouthful of everything can you do
that so for example i go here right up
and down
not up and down oh
i just went down really that's good okay
so let me go up
[Applause]
ain't no one fatter than me trust me
being a fat boy okay so i do this right
suck it up here
now i gotta do the bart method
see
you know where i got that technique from
drinking root beer floats the root beer
float is all about both root beer and
the ice cream so i go
like that
that's good
oh my god so i've never gotten the
coffee or i feel like i need to eat it
with a spoon oh it's dripping over the
side you see that i think it's melted
marshmallow how do i approach this i
don't know just drink it
whoa it's floating on it's thick
it's melted marshmallow on the top
[Music]
it's good it's melted marshmallow and
it's the way you like it is you don't
like that much chocolate so it's melted
marshmallow coffee with just a little
bit of chocolate at the top okay this
one was kind of underwhelming
let's see this one's
[Music]
okay
don't steal my graham cracker don't you
dare i'm up so get that
[Music]
look at how big this is look at your
okay look at this what's bigger your
head or the pancake
what's bigger
no way look at this like this
this is also a big phone too it's the
max
this is bigger than my head monkey
[Music]
all right so we came here for the
pancake i think we found the biggest
pancake of vegas i don't know you guys
tell me
so i have to try this first i love a
pancake that's crispy on the top and
fluffy on the inside and i'm gonna eat
with my hands type of guy i see the
blueberries i see the powdered sugar and
the lemon
after really good context
look at that texture
nice little crust
soft on the inside you see that
now to the real deal this is what i'm
really excited for
i'm a huge chicken and waffles fan i
love fried chicken so before i mix the
two i gotta get chicken by itself i
gotta see how juicy it is how crunchy it
is
got some chicken
that's a maple syrup
with some nashville hot sauce
[Laughter]
[Music]
great fried chicken
love all these herbs like onions
i love herbs gives it a really aromatic
taste
juicy white meat which is hard to do
love that crunch all right time to get a
little bit of both now this is the match
made in heaven and this is why they
created this dish you get a little bit
of this
a little bit of that a little bit of
this
right here
put it together
[Applause]
it's on the spicier side for me but it's
really good i could really taste the
chorizo in it it had potatoes in here
super crunchy on the outside it's just
heaven it's really good they put
jalapenos in here so that's that's nice
little pick and it's smothered in
cheddar cheese
[Applause]
it's actually pretty good
yeah
it's actually pretty good if you don't
want it to be heavier don't eat the
potatoes as much but i ordered it with
sour cream and a side of avocado
totally worth it totally
oh my god that's so frenchy
okay there with that okay what else am i
doing
i'll do this
there's no bone in it you don't have to
worry about eating around the bone
it's like a chicken breast but it's so
juicy and crunchy
that's bomb i like yours better all
right ma bears try at the pancakes
yeah yeah yeah i always
[Applause]
yeah i think that was optional and
she was like do you want lemon on top
and you were like yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
anytime the server recommends something
most servers have ate everything that
the restaurant has to offer so if they
go would you like with a lemon i go
i know what you're trying to say and yes
please all right so let's discover
how this is so juicy there's actually
two pieces of fried chicken on here look
at that
break it in half
look at that look at all that juice in
there
dip it in here oh my god dip a little
bit here
you want them no no no no
it's just chicken
back to the herbs man
[Music]
all right so that was a super yummy and
huge
pancake i know i came here looking for
pancakes but one thing i did not realize
that i was gonna get and i should have
known from just the size of the pancake
is how big the portions are there's
enough food on there to feed us for two
or three more breakfasts but i had to
try everything so if you guys are gonna
come make sure you keep breathing
stomach empty can on empty that you
cannot empty in your freaking chest
underneath it yes or you can order one
thing and probably share it with like
three or four people sure or just order
the breakfast
and just plan to have it for two or
three more days what is something that
you were expecting so the beginning of
this video i was saying how i'm not like
much of a breakfast person because i
just don't do that much sweets so that's
why i ordered the chorizo and i was so
surprised that that was actually my
least favorite really yeah because um
you thought that was going to be your
favorite yeah because i'm more of a
savory person
but then when i heard the blueberry and
then you're like you opted for the lemon
sauce
i was like
let me try this out so when i bought
when i bit into it i was like oh crap i
think that might even be my favorite
um pancake spot because i'm like if
we're gonna battle we're gonna be like
pancake or waffles yo waffles all day
because it's crispy on the outside warm
and gooey on the inside texture so much
going on
are you flirting or what the hell always
um
yeah but then when i got the pancake it
was the same thing it was like a flat
waffle where it was crunchy on the
outside and gooey on the inside and it
was like the perfect amount of sweetness
so it's crazy they made such a big
pancake great yeah i wonder what the
size of the pan is is it even a pan how
about you monkey would you like baby did
you like the pancakes the blueberry was
your favorite
the blueberry pancakes it's a big old
amount
you eat so much
good job monkey
so yeah we came before the pancakes one
thing that was also super good was the
campfire s'mores latte yes i did not
expect a drink
to freaking knock my socks off but it
did so if you guys are ever out in vegas
looking for some big delicious pancake
make sure you check out hash house a
go-go it's super fun lots of food great
environment i super recommend it make
sure you go check that out and thank you
guys for following us as we continue to
get lost in vegas and explore the rest
of the world
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you